she saw them but she did not believe
they were there you see she saw them in
their pens so often in her dreams that
she thought this was just the dream
let's ask you if the parents at the end
seemingly think that the kids what is
that I wonder that we look first kaisers
in the building tonight I'm gonna ask
him myself
what does that meant to mean to us as
viewers well I mean there are a couple
of things the first thing it needs to
mean is that earth exists in other words
one of the big questions of the season
asks and the kids ask is is there a
place to go home to they don't know the
answer to that they still don't know the
answer but you and I do so we have hope
there will that end that is hope
I actually think more than about it's
more than about grief it's about hope I
think it is I don't know I feel like I
don't want to give away too much but in
Episode six there's a dog and everyone
thinks that the dog was killed with in
episode 10 the dog appears again in the
real world or whatever this real world
is so maybe maybe there is the way back
the world doesn't just turn upside down
without a reason we're not in some play
within a play
the question is one is where are they
the second question is why are they
there what crimes happened in Westham
for which they were either punished or
from which they were saying that's the
really big question isn't I mean the
question does help to wit when can they
get back but how can they get back
that's gonna come at the end of the seal
for this serie but I think we need to
know a little bit more about why they're
there are we gonna explore that and
seasons who are you guys talking about
that
we see more of the parents I don't know
you know we way early on we've talked
about to seeing the parents more and
we'd pulled back on that I think we now
have the flexibility to go back if we
want to I'm gonna let see how that goes
I mean it's interesting to take it from
that perspective but we hate leaving the
case we'll feel like they
you need to know more by the end of
season 1 so they'll they'll definitely
want to see them too because we don't
reveal very very much that's diligence
that's like a hundred questions that not
many answers God doesn't just play games
with people for fun what one biggest
question that you would like to see
answered in a season two I guess like
how like is it like a he says what is it
what is it like is it another universe
is it are they dead are they not dead
like do they go back in time folding
time like something that the logistics
of it merely pride me like there's all
that stuff about the Eclipse and
everything and like on a scientific
level what is going on
[Music]